так всё-таки пахать или не пахать И
вообще сколько нужно работать для того
чтобы зарабатывать большие деньги в сети
ходит очень много мемов по поводу моего
высказывания что не надо пахать в то же
время есть очень много блогеров которые
говорят что надо пахать целыми днями
надо пахать 24 на 7 даже есть та такое
мнение Сколько реально нужно пахать для
того чтобы зарабатывать большие деньги
этот вопрос не такой простой как кажется
на первый взгляд людям свойст порива всё
и доводить до крайностей люди думают что
нужно либо пахать либо не пахать они как
бы противопоставляют на самом деле
секрет в том что нужно пахать как
угорелый и не пахать истина спрятана вон
там давайте поговорим об этом что нужно
делать для зарабатывания больших денег
пахать или не пахать если Вам эта тема
интересна Ставьте лайк Подписывайтесь А
мы пойдём дальше многие люди упрощают
этот вопрос и они смотрят либо пахать
либо не пахать на самом деле нужно
пахать но просто нужно знать где и
сколько пахать Давайте Я приведу вам
пример вот в чём фокус и вообще В чём
отличие богатых людей или успешных людей
от неуспешных людей Дело в том что
успешных людей от неуспешных людей
отличает не то что они что-то делают
по-другому вот есть распространённый миф
или распространённое Утверждение что
богатые люди делают всё по-другому на
самом деле В чём суть того что они
делают по-другому вы думаете они у них
маркетинг строится по-другому Нет тот же
самый маркетинг продажи по-другому нет
маркетинг и продажи то же самое людей
они нанимают по-другому тоже самое то
есть все всё что касается бизнес
инструментов они делают тоже самое что и
Вы другой вопрос что они делают
по-другому а другое они делают то что
они держат фокус на ключевых точках они
занимаются ключевыми вещами так вот
ответом на вопрос пахать или не пахать Я
приведу такую метафору или расскажу в
виде истории Представьте что вы строите
сорока этажный небоскрёб Если вы в
фундаменте допустите маленькую трещин то
эта трещина приведёт вас на сороковом
этаже к катастрофе здесь работает закон
который гласит малень
ошибка в начальных условиях всегда
приводит к катастрофе в конце Именно
поэтому Когда вы строите большой
небоскрёб Вы должны быть перфекционистом
и пахарем на стадии строительства
фундамента первого и второго этажа
Почему на стадии фундамента Вам наверное
и так понятно да потому что фундамент
должен быть реально идеальный А почему
на стадии первого второго этажа потому
что это те этажи которые видны которые
люди могут пощупать в которых находятся
коммерческие помещения они могут
пощупать сравнить материал и через этот
материал который вы применили при
строительстве они могут судить о
качестве всего здания поэтому фундамент
первый и второй этаж - это наиболее
критическая часть здания и вот здесь вы
должны пахать как угорелый и вот здесь
вы должны быть не просто перфекционистом
А
параноиком дальше чем выше больше этажей
вы строите тем больше вы делегирует на
команд
больше больше больше она там начиная от
три пго этажа или до сорокового этажа
там уже полностью команда может сама
строить причём может делать из
пенопласта эти этажи они всё равно снизу
не видны
непонятно никто не может пощупать
посмотреть и так далее поэтому критичная
часть - это
начальные начальная часть Давайте сним
посмотрим на бизнес Когда Вы начинаете
бизнес
лж определить ключевой фактор успеха Что
является ключевым в вашем бизнесе раз
во-вторых Вы должны сформировать команду
в-третьих Вы должны дать миссию компании
и всей команде Объяснить смысл зачем мы
вместе собрались и что мы делаем для
кого мы делаем в четвёртых Вы должны
создать корпоративную культуру или
культуру взаимоотношений в компании в
пятых Вы должны прописать
первые взаимоотношения
с генеральным директором который вы найм
или вашим помощником или может быть
заместителем и так далее То есть вы
закладывает и в это время вам надо быть
перфекционистом а дальше по мере роста
развитие компании уже многие вещи будут
делаться самими сотрудниками если взять
опять это здание Как пример то смотрите
во всём здании Если вы пате на стадии
фундамента первого второго этажа а
дальше меньше и меньше то люди со
стороны скажут вот сорока этажное здание
маргулан построил из них он только 20%
максимум пахал 80% сделала команда и это
будет правда но в этих 20% которые я
пахал я пахал там 100% времени на стадии
фундамента первого второго этажа то есть
нужно понимать когда вы должны пахать на
100% И где вы должны быть
перфекционистом и нужно понимать когда
уже вашего участия такого не требуется
поэтому на вопрос пахать или не пахать я
твёрдо отвечаю вам нужно пахать на всех
ключевых точках И вам нужно быть
перфекционистом во всех ключевых точках
всё остальное Вы можете делегировать Вы
можете привлекать подрядчиков сторонних
Вы можете привлекать поставщиков и так
далее и так далее если это не Ключевое
для вашего бизнеса собственник компании
обычно чем он должен заниматься он
должен заниматься принятием решений
результаты которых будут через год 2 3 5
лет а операционный менеджмент должн
заниматься решением ежедневных проблем
Вот что значит в операционных вопросах
вы не Паше А в стратегически важных
вопросах вы Паше как маньяк здесь надо
отметить что существует категория людей
которые по жизни пашут всегда А есть
категория людей которые работают очень
мало так вот для них я особенно скажу
смотрите те собственники компании Или те
люди которые пат всегда очень
часто сю эффективность у меня есть такое
высказывание где я говорю там Где ваша
сила там ваша слабость то есть из-за
того что вы супер пахар вы начинаете
вмешиваться во все дела в компании и вы
не даёте раскрыться менеджменту и в
результате менеджмент у вас не
дорабатывает вы всё время влезает Это
почему происходит Это происходит потому
что вы не понимаете суть делегирования и
пахоты суть делегирования заключается не
в том чтобы делегировать эти операции
менеджменту а потом курить бамбук нет
суть делегирования заключается в том
чтобы делегировать рутинные операции
менеджменту А самому пахать в
стратегических вопросах ключевых
вопросах то есть продолжать пахать на
самом деле делегирование - это Есть
нечто иное как просто смена фокуса ты до
этого занимался всеми операциями А
сейчас ты пашешь но в стратегических
операциях Это для тех кто привык и любит
много пахать для тех кто не любит много
работать учитывая ваш темперамент и ваше
нежелание много работать сразу
сосредоточьтесь на самых ключевых
вопросах и в результате вы не будете
обременять себя операционными рутинные
операциями А вот то время которое вы
работаете всё ваше творческие весь ваш
творческий потенциал всю вашу энергию
Соберите фокус и займитесь только
ключевыми вещами и этого будет
достаточно чтобы компания росла и
процветала Поделитесь пожалуйста в
комментариях о том вы к какому типу
людей относитесь И вообще какие у вас в
голове убеждения надо пахать или не надо
Пахать и э как это на вас сказывается
вот я в своей жизни достиг очень многих
высот заработал миллиарды долларов и я
не помню чтобы я пахал больше 6 часов в
день 6 часов в день достаточно для того
чтобы достичь любых успехов и любых
богатств это моё личное глубокое
убеждение если вам не хватает сти или
8ми часов в день то это говорит только
об одном то что а вы неэффективны б то
что вы не доверяете людям иц вы не
умеете делегировать и вы не знаете на
чём концентрироваться вы не знаете
ключевые точки или ключевые факторы на
чём держать фокус многие меня спрашивают
А вот в эти 6 часов которой вы работаете
Туда входит там обучение чтение книг
которые развивает вас а YouTube видео
там нетворкинг встречи и так далее и так
далее смотрите если это прямо влияет на
рост вашего бизнеса на ваш рост тогда да
входит если это что-то отвлечённые тогда
не входит то есть в конечном итоге вы в
эти 6 часов должны заниматься только тем
что является ключевым и что я прямо
влияет на рост вас и вашего бизнеса и
Неважно как это называется встреча
YouTube видео собрание совещание отчёт
либо печатание на компьютере чего-то не
имеет значения какой Вите чтобы это было
ключевым которое прямо влияет на рост
вашего бизнеса и вас лично